when it eventually happened it felt like  stopping a like running train i think  that that's why i felt emotional at the  end and why it was painful and i don't  like that i don't like being in confined  spaces i was like really uncomfortable  with the idea  it gives like a nice like yeah comedic  break and all the madness that's  happening but i never thought it would  escalate that far  oh that needle it looks like it hurts  that was acting it's hard to watch for  the first time sorry i'm stuck  it made me want to cry like no pull it  together  they're crazy  i actually kind of  let all of his insecurities come out so  for me it was like humbling in a way